as we said before we'll be using
template HTML to build our awesome
resumes to do so we'll be using the
string dot replace method to find a
pattern in a string and replace all or
some matches of it we'll be using the
most simple version to find the first
instance of a pattern but you can do
much more
check the instructors notes for more
details let's take my email address as
an example if I wanted to change out my
Udacity email address for a gmail email
address I could use a replace function
in this case I've got var new email
equals email the string with my Udacity
email address and I'm replacing Udacity
with Gmail and don't forget to check to
see if that worked right let me add
console dot log email to see my old
email address and console dot log new
email to see my new email address ok
we're going to refresh our page open up
the console and there we go we can see
my old Udacity email address showing up
on the console as well as my new gmail
address on the console as well let's
have the students try but this time
let's append the new message to the page
I want you to create a new var called
fun thoughts where you take everything
that was in awesome thoughts but replace
the word awesome
with fun used at append funds and put it
on the page check this box when you see
your message show up on the page